الناس تعاني من لا لا معها تدفع ولا معها
تشتري دواء الناس الله يكون بعونها على
اللي انا شايفه الله يكون بعون الناس يعني
اللي بيجينا لا ما احنا اجر وما اجر بطلب
نهائيا يعني كله لوجه
[موسيقى]
الله حكيم زكي شاهين خضر مدرس تمريض
الجامعه في جامعه الازهر وكليه فلسطين
للتمريض والله احنا هنا شغلنا كله يتركز
على الحاجه الانسانيه يعني الحاره مليانه
شباب ومليانه الدنيا زحمه الان عننا ف
اللي بيجي مجروح اللي بيجي مكسور اللي
بيجي مطبوش اللي بيجي طشات مع بعض الناس
فبن بنعمل غرز بنعمل غيار اللي بيجي عنده
اسهال عنده نتج بنتعالج معه انا معي
ماجستير في التمريض وبناء عليه عندي
صلاحيات اشتغل عليها الان احنا فتحنا نقطه
طبيه هنا في نص الحاره على اساس خدمه
الناس والمواطنين والاهالي بكل ما يحتاجه
والحمد لله الامور يعني طيبه ولا ولا
نتقاضى اجر يعني لا نتقاضى اجر عمل انساني
التموين والادوات اللي من عننا بنامن من
من المصادر اللي بنقدر نجيبها منها بتيجي
عننا لانه اولا الدنيا بتكون مرار ليل
وزحمه وال المستشفيات لا تقبل الحالات
المشاجرات في الليل مستشفيات مش فاضيه
للمشاجرات يعني عندها ح وادس وعند هذا فكل
الحالات السهله والبسيطه حولوها علينا
واحنا عننا اكثر من نقطه طبيه يعني في
حاله بتجينا تستدعي وجود مستشفى بطلب
الاسعاف وبحول على
طول والله الناس وضعها صعب يعني انا انا
شايف انه وضع الناس صعب وهذه النقات
الطبيه مطلوبه جدا الان في الفتره هذه
اللي احنا فيها يعني المستشفيات زحمه
المستشفيات مليانه وهذا عمل انساني بحت
والحمد لله
العياده موجوده في في البيت فبن شغل على
على الامد البعيد في الموضوع هذا يعني
عننا العلاجات وبنضل من الساعه 7:00 الى
الساعه 11 واحنا قاعدين والله لحالي انا
بقدر اجيب يعني زملائي لما استدعي بيجوني
والله هذا المحل كان محل تجاره عامه و
وخلصت كل الادوات اللي فيه يعني نباع كل
شيء فيه من زحمه الناس فقلنا نعمل نقطه
طبيه بدل ما ناجر وناج ونضيع وقت على
الفاضي قلنا ب نعمل نقطه طبيه منها لله
ومنها مساعده ومنها خدمات انسانيه بتشكر
الناس والناس وضعها صعب جدا يعني الناس
تعاني من لا لا معها تدفع ولا معها تشتري
دواء الناس الله يكون بعونها على اللي انا
شايفه الله يكون بعون الناس يعني اللي
بيجينا لا ما احنا اجر وما اجر بطلب
نهائيا يعني كله لوجه الله طالما عننا
الادوات وعننا التسهيلات ونحن بنشتغل لله
لله مش اكثر ومساعده انسانيه
[موسيقى]